وينضم الينا من غازي عنتاب مراسل الجزيره
يونس ايه ياسين اهلا وسهلا بك يونس يونس
اخر ملامح المشهد
المشهد محمد مرحبا بك المشهد مازال مستمر
يعني جهود الانقاذ والاسعاف ومحاوله البحث
عن ناجين ما تزال تكلل بالنجاح على الرغم
ان يعني الامل يضمح لنا مع مرور الوقت نحن
نتحدث عن الان نعيش الساعه التاسعه
والسبعين بعد المئتين وبالتالي الامال
المتضائله بالعثور على ناجين لكن جهود
يعني فرق الانقاذ ومغالبه التعب مغالبه
الظروف والطقس نحن الان يعني درجه الحراره
في غازي عنتاب التي لم تتاثر بشكل كبير
بالمقارنه مثلا مع الولايات كهرمان مرعش
انطاكيا رميان يعني لم تتاثر كثيرا لكن
درجه الحراره منخفضه ومع ذلك فرق الانقاذ
ما تزال مستمره عمليات الانقاذ في غازي
عنتاب حيث نتواجد عمليا توقفت لانه عدد
المباني التي تضررت قليل جدا وبالتالي تم
مسحها
الفرق الانقاذ الان يعني تركز على
استخراج المواد
الاساسيه مواد البناء من اجل فتح تحقيق
مستقبلا في
الامكانيه وجود فساد في عمليات البناء
المشهد كما ترى يعني كما تعرضه
الكاميرا محمد هذا المخيم انشاته البلديه
بعد ايام مباشره بعد زلزال القاطنون فيه
ظروفهم قد تحسنت كثيرا بالمقارنه مع مكان
عليه الوضع مباشره بعد الزلزال هذه الخيام
توفر التدفئه الحد الادنى من ظروف العيش
في كل خيمه توجد يعني وسائل تدفئه يتم
توفير الطعام من خلال المراكز التي اعدتها
بلديه غازي عنتاب والتي توفر وجبات بمئات
الالاف لسكان ولايه غازي عنتاب عمليات
التفتيش في المباني التي تضررت يعني قطعه
اشواط كبيره في ولايه غازي عنتاب حيث
نتواجد 70% من عمليات قد تمت وتم تصنيف
المباني حسب تضررها هناك مباني تضررت بشكل
طفيف هناك مباني تضرط بشكل كبير وبالتالي
الان سوف يتم جرد هذه المباني ومعرفه بعد
ذلك هل سوف يتم دعوه السكان بالعوده اليها
ام انه سوف يتم هدمها لانها لم تعد قادره
على استيعاب سكانها
الارقام التي تتصلنا بشكل يعني دوري محمد
تعكس حقيقه شيء ربما لافت الانتباه وهو
انه بعد عشره ايام ما يزال فرق الانقاذ
تنجح في انتشال الناجين اليوم في كهرمان
مرعش يعني تم انتشال سيده تبلغ من العمر
77 سنه وايضا طفل سيده وطفلين في ولايه
هاتايا التي تاخرت فيها عمليات الانقاذ
بالنظر الى وجودها في اقصى الجنوب التركي
ما تزال فرق الانقاذ تنجح ايضا في الوصول
الى ناجين على الرغم من حاله الدمار
الكبيره التي شهدتها هذه الولايه والتي
كنا فيها قبل ثلاثه ايام هو حقيقه المشهد
كان الصادم جدا بالنظر الى وجود احياء
كامله مدمره وهذا ايضا يطرح اشكالات اخرى
مستقبليه فيما يتعلق بالتحذيرات التي
اصدرتها الحكومه التركيه والتي عكست ايضا
تصريحات منظمه الصحه العالميه من التحذير
من الامراض التي قد تنتشر في الولايه بسبب
الجثث المتحلله التي يعني توجد تحت الركام
والتي يصعب على فرق الانقاذ الوصول اليها
بالحديث عن بروده الطقس محمد ربما قد تكون
هذه نعمه في طي نقمه لان بروده الطقس قد
تحول او قد تؤخر عمليه تحلل الجثث لكن هذا
يبقى خطرا يهدد سكان المنطقه الذين
يفترشون يعني الذين يعيشون في الساحات
ويهدد ايضا اطقم الانقاذ التي يعني تكثف
محاولاتها في في سعيها للوصول الى ناجين
هناك وعود رسميه من الحكومه التركيه بانها
سوف
تقوم بمجهود كبير من اجل اعاده الاعمار
بشكل قياسي خلال سنه حسب الحكومه التركيه
سوف يتم اعاده بناء المنازل المهدمه لكن
هذا تحدي كبير بالنظر الى العدد الكبير
للمنازل المتضرره هناك حديث اليوم عن
خمسين الف مبنى يعني
مهدد بالسقوط وبالتالي قد تلجا الحكومه
التركيه الى يعني هدمها للنظر الى انها لم
تعد قادره على استيعاب ساكنها محمد شكرا
شكرا جزيلا لك يونس سيد ياسين من غازي
عنتاب